welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is cave a cushion hood an associate
professor at the School of Public Health
at yale university professor cush node
is an infectious disease epidemiologist
and his primary research interests are
the epidemiology prevention and control
of hiv/aids and tuberculosis among drug
users prisoners and other at-risk
populations in the United States and in
resource-poor countries he also mentors
researchers from around the world and
teaches courses on hiv/aids global
health and research methods and ethics
today we talk with him about global
health education and how to conduct
research in resource-poor settings
welcome professor Krishna thank you it's
good to be here interest in global
health education has dramatically
increased over the past few years us
particularly here at Yale why do you
think that is it is true i would say in
the last 10 years or so we have seen an
increase in global health interest in
colleges and universities across the
united states i haven't seen a
definitive study a report that talks
about what are the factors that are
behind this interest but there are some
speculations and there are factors that
have been identified and i would say all
these factors are interrelated first I
would say globalization the fact that we
are now connected in ways that we were
not connected before so we can be aware
of events happening halfway around the
world in an instance so if there's a
famine going on or there is there are
health issues we can become aware of
them and the students become very
interested and engaged universities are
becoming globalized the curriculum is
changing there's more international
students that are coming to
and they're more students from Yale
going abroad so they're having these
experiences the other factor i would say
is the AIDS pandemic AIDS is the plague
of our time and I think the devastation
of AIDS pandemic but also the response
has been a source of inspiration and has
captured the imagination of many of our
students so they get very interested in
involved in AIDS related work and then
from there they move on to other global
health issues and I have seen that
happening in our own campus also the
amount of resources that are allocated
to global health has increased
tremendously that is true from public
sources from government but also from
foundations if you just think of the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation if you
think of the Clinton Foundation there's
just a lot more funds available which
means there are more jobs and career
choices available for our students we
can't underestimate the role of
celebrities if you think of bottle sure
there are people who are now engaged in
global health that young people tend to
pay attention to and finally i would say
911 and aftermath of 911 and the two
wars that have been going on i think for
some of our students at responds to
what's been happening is a desire to
want to heal the world and they get
involved in global health issues how did
you yourself become involved in global
health well my parents are both
physicians so I was kind of in the
health exposed to health issues from a
young age and also i was born in iran
and came to United States at the age of
17 so I was kind of already familiar
with being an immigrant and some of the
health issues the immigrants have to
deal with so when I chose I was
interested in medicine initially and
then decided to move towards more of a
public health career so I came to Yale
to pursue a public health degree and
when i came in late 80s i was interested
in what was then called international
health and I remember there was
literally a single course at our school
of public health and things have
certainly changed since that and how you
do teach students how to go out into the
world and do research how do you go
about training them what are some things
that in particular that they need to be
very aware of right i would say for
graduate students there are a number of
courses that offers them research
methods and they could be quite equipped
to go into the field to do the work but
I've noticed that among our
undergraduates there weren't too many
courses that prepare them for taking on
independent research projects so a few
years ago i started a global health
research workshop this was a non-credit
workshop which simply engaged with
undergraduate students who increasingly
were asking for assistance to do
independent research in some very
difficult situations so that workshop
went on for about three years and then
in 2009 I turned that into a course so
now there's a course that I teach that I
think you mentioned it it's a global
health research methods and ethics
course and we spend the whole semester
working with undergraduates primarily to
take their ideas an interest in global
health and turn it into a feasible
scientifically sound ethically sound
research projects how can you give an
example of a student that has gone to
Africa for for example and what have
they done there Oh give us a feel for
what exactly they're doing sure the
students actually quite ambitious the
kinds of students that I interact with
tend to want to work in the field they
want to work in resource-poor research
limited countries throughout the world
some of them actually in the United
States I've had students who wanted to
work in inner city or in the
reservations etc and we remind them that
United States is part of the globe so it
is ok to do research on what students
have looked at
past year look that hypertension in
Kenya when we think a lot of the African
countries we often think of infectious
diseases which are still very common and
prevalent there but there's a rise in
chronic diseases and risk factors for
those such as hypertension I had a
student who was quite interested in the
rise in obesity among children in china
so she went there and she worked with
kindergarten students and basically
observed their eating habits and
nutritional habits and sort of did a
study of that are there any surprises or
things that students need to be aware of
that perhaps they they don't necessarily
think of before they embarked on a
project abroad I would say definitely
yes it's always the case that when they
go abroad they are confronted with
situations that they were not really
used to but i must say that increasingly
we're finding that our students are
well-travelled you know they've spent
weeks sometimes months just traveling
with family or just doing volunteer work
but now they want to go back and do an
actual research project nevertheless
they're often surprised by the level of
poverty the witness but also lack of
basic medical care poor infrastructure
talking about roads I'm talking about
electricity I'm talking about having
access to internet they're so used to
being plugged in all the time and
getting answers to questions they may
have and now they're in a situation
where there's no electricity they cannot
connect to the internet and they have to
do a lot of problem-solving on their own
without access to the outside world so
it does tend to surprise them the other
thing that I've heard from students is
the sense of hope and resiliency that
some of the people who are really
struggling with very difficult
situations nevertheless sort of have
this hopefulness about them
and tend to thrive under very difficult
situation and that's quite inspiring for
our students to see what about some of
the ethical considerations do you do
have certain guidelines that students
have to follow around the ethics of
going to another country and dealing
with sensitive perhaps medical
information that kind of thing
absolutely I would say we've been taking
the ethical issues very seriously in the
last couple of years and as I tell my
students ethics and research methods go
hand in hand and ethical issues should
not be an afterthought it should be
something that they think about from the
design phase when they're thinking about
their proposal and beginning to put
their proposal together all the way
through when they're in the field
conducting the research and then coming
back and analyzing the results and
thinking about how those results should
be used to improve the situation that
they may witness so yes there's been a
lot of emphasis on that what are some of
the ethical issue you know what comes up
I would say maybe I think we can put the
ethical issues into three buckets one
are sort of human subjects issues the
kinds of things we think about in terms
of informal consent voluntary
participation etc there are others that
are more about regulation of research so
that includes things like if you want to
go overseas and if you want to do
research in another country the
requirements are that you seek approval
ethical approval from your own
institution so Yale but you also need to
get a local IRB or institutional review
board to approve your project so there
is need for dual approval and some of
the students are not aware of this they
arrive at the sort of host country host
institution and they're surprised to
find out that their Yale approval is not
sufficient so we try to prepare them for
that but I would say that the most
challenging one is personal ethics
because again they're confronted with
issues and situations where they're not
quite sure what to do that they go to do
research and uncover a lot of unmet
health needs whether there are former
child soldiers and they've been
interviewing them about mental health
issues or they're working with street
children in a slums of Kenya they feel
hopeless and helpless in terms of being
able to actually meet the needs of those
children once the research is done so
they come back sometimes quite i would
say disturbed by some of the things they
have seen and they they have a need to
talk about it and we do we've been
increasing the providing sort of forum
for them to discuss these ethical issues
that they have encountered when they
come back and in fact some of the
medical students who came back few years
ago we had a series of discussions and
they decided that these ethical issues
that they have been confronting with
it's worth writing them as a case study
to use as an educational tool and then
we found out there was interest in
medical schools all around the country
in our case studies because they were
being confronted the same issues and
those case studies have now been
published and they have been made
available to other schools where they
are sending students overseas very good
and culturally I would imagine students
must get some kind of training or and
language too so you know how are they
prepared in terms of language and being
culturally aware i would say hugely
important and linguistic skills cultural
competencies I at least tend to
emphasize the fact that if you are going
to another country to conduct research
you must have a working knowledge of the
local language and many students
actually do
it also depends on the kind of research
they're about to undertake if it's
mostly a sort of laboratory based
research project they are not they don't
a certain need to have proficiency in
the local language often the people who
are working in the medical field speak
English but if they're going out into
the community and going into the field
and doing more qualitative research they
really need to understand the language
and they need to be proficient in it
because relying on somebody to translate
for you it's really not the best way to
get valid data sure and finally where do
you think global health education is
going down the road great question the
universities are really this is sort of
what they've been thinking about and
there are literally drafts being
circulated among universities that
begins to define what are the core
competencies so if you're developing a
global health program what are the core
competencies that we want the students
to have and it is an evolving field
people are sort of trying to get their
minds around it and it's very much
something that Yale is involved in and
there's actually a meeting coming up in
November in Montreal and part of that is
to get global health educators together
to talk about some of these issues of
what are the main issues that we need to
communicate to our students and prepare
them very good thank you so much for
being here with us today you must
welcome thank you for more information
about professor cush nut and his
research please visit our website at
yale edu backslash macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale